pokemons go more like pokemons holes
well you know what I've had enough I'm
sick and tired of catching piggies
I want my weight back I want my white
face back
I want my social awkwardness back the
game [ __ ] I'm tired I'm never touching
any Pokemon game again you ruined my
trust [ __ ] [ __ ]
what is this pokemons autism edition
could it be whoa those are some cool
avatars well the guy gets a sword I
think that's a little sexist man that
looks so good I have to play this game
this is my core message okay I get to
pick my team well obviously I'm gonna
pick team mistake because I don't eat my
own [ __ ] wow this game looks real good
this is already so much better I better
put on my favorite song while playing
this wait wait wait this is the best
Pokemon game look at it that is [ __ ]
good man you can now lift weights while
catching pokémon see here we have Lucas
he's three years old he loves Pokemon
and has no dad or mom I grabbed my phone
hey there's a polka shop Oh day long
I play pokemons go every day
[Music]
I haven't caught a single [ __ ]
Pokemon yeah I'm a disgrace to ash oh oh
oh there's a Weedle okay come on
I need that weasel I need that Whittle
come hey man I caught a Weedle jealous
hater I can't climb the ladder that way
but I can climb it this oh I died I died
everyone where the [ __ ] are all the
pokemons oh here's a balloon wait -
Sammy oh I'm coming for you sharise
there's a rice you red day that's all
right you come up oh my god I got a
catchy I gotta catch that cinema what
that [ __ ] ah I got you now rice you here
we go
spin around gotta bump you right shoot
your piece of [ __ ] you mind I got a I
shot oh why why kill me please I want to
die
what is happy what is happening oh oh
god oh god oh god oh god hey hey we got
a we got a one of those you want hey you
[ __ ] [ __ ] bad man that was my
[ __ ] Pokemon [ __ ] [ __ ]
come on catch it before come on come on
[ __ ] bad man again bad man again are
you [ __ ] kidding me
Oh Kelly I'll [ __ ] Kelly dude it's not
a Weedle or a penis oh [ __ ] it was a
penis what the actual [ __ ] is this no no
no no no I can't even look at who did
this who did this damn I look swag this
game just got a lot [ __ ] better guys
I can be a Pokemon now hopefully none of
these haters will catch me [ __ ] you
no [ __ ] you no no get away get away from
me get away from me [ __ ] let's enjoy
the Sun Wow
yeah wow that's that's real nice
hey I'm Sasuke
[Music]
oh dude my avatar is so cool shut up
shut the [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] am i
doing
hey I'm not a Pokemon you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you racist piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
Poliwhirl justice I remember him [ __ ] I
can't oh I've never been this pissed
that's a rat attack that's an Rattata
hurry hurry hurry
my Rattata my [ __ ] rat attack my foot
y'all better [ __ ] off my rat attack Oh
[ __ ] you can [ __ ] yourself or mine
you Lego looking [ __ ] scrub do you
team Instinct piece of [ __ ] I hope you
die I hope you get a disease why don't
you guys pick the pretty pie outfit huh
you guys like Buddha pie huh I mean he's
pretty okay I guess for 2013 photo pie
was better dodo there's a dodo there
doesn't know how to get up stupid piece
of [ __ ] I got that dodo T means stick
piece of [ __ ] yeah you can suck it you
want to poop this abyss here have a
pizza hey you have a pizza instead come
on buddy
you don't even have arms people with no
arms can't play this game you're [ __ ]
losers how are you gonna catch the balls
have a piece
[Music]
oh my god did I just kill him
[Music]
I think I think I made him oh okay
does this game suck up your battery life
no does this game freeze at the worst
times hell no
isn't that right Easley it's this game
pay2win hell no guys we need to start
playing Pokemon go and start playing
Pokemon oh I'm gonna leave this game in
the description so we all can play
together is so much fun
please leave a like if you enjoyed and
as always stay awesome press
[Music]